good evening ladies and gentlemen at
work my name is Stefan Simone I'm the
director of the
for the preservation of cultural
heritage and it's my great pleasure to
welcome you tonight to a special lecture
in what we call the serious dialogues
and heritage science but actually it's
not so much our series at the Institute
for preservation of cultural heritage is
actually a co-sponsored event with
master Malu from the Timothy Dwight
college and it's the opening of what you
have seen outside and what will be with
us for the next more than 10 days the
United Nation global colloquium for the
preservation of cultural heritage which
will be hosted at Yale and it's a great
pleasure to have Sarah Parker here to
open that Sarah is a Yale graduate class
of 2001 and I can look around and see
many colleagues from the archaeological
and anthropological departments she
actually was majoring in archaeological
studies right and you have also a very
close relationship to the Near Eastern
languages Department and that makes
Sarah coming home home to Yale with
something which is actually brand-new
archaeology primarily has been seen as a
as a ground-based endeavor you know
digging out things collecting things but
but Sarah turned this I mean into into
into the 21st century I would say with a
lot of space and airborne based remote
sensing technologies satellite imaging
actually I first met Sarah on Twitter
with her action in India from space and
I thought that's really cool and and
she's tremendously successful I mean
just just recently if you follow the
news like half a year ago I knew her I
knew you from Egypt mostly and now
I know her from Newfoundland because I
discovered a Viking settlement and and
the the link to to the preservation of
cultural heritage which is most
prominent in her work and I am very
proud that she will speak to us tonight
is connected to to an issue which was
close to our hearts in the cultural
heritage community since many years but
most recently more and more the looting
of ancient sites the illicit traffic
which goes on on an industrial scale not
only in the Middle East we have we're
seeing that in of course in the Middle
East but also in Africa also in Asia
also actually in North America in many
regions of the world and the modern
tools developed by Sarah who is now
actually professor associate professor
of anthropology at the University of
Alabama in Birmingham and the founding
director of the UAB laboratory for
global observation her great success
the terawatt 2016 she will speak about
that how that links to her initiative of
crowdsourcing this struggle against
looting and illicit traffic and before I
welcome Sarah on the stage I would like
to to tell you that there will be
another event actually the master tea
tomorrow at 4:30 in the Tim OTT white
house and I would like to with Sarah and
I wherever especially undergrads can
come and learn about Sarah's career how
she started out and how she got where
she's now but also take this button with
you unite for heritage the the logo I
think or the mission for the next ten
days here at Yale with many many events
following Sarah's presentation so please
join me in welcoming Sarah Park
thank you
I can't tell you what an incredible
pleasure and honor it is to be back here
although given the time of year I I'm
just wandering around going don't I have
a final paper due actually it's a lot of
overdue articles but I think the risk is
a little little lower I first want to
start by thanking Marion Stefan for
their incredibly kind invitations to
speak here and also the amazing time and
effort that they've put into putting on
this event as well as the one tomorrow
actually we're talking about this today
I got separate invitations from both of
them within 24 hours and if that's not
mother year calling you home I don't
know what is so it's just really
wonderful to be back here it's also a
real pleasure to be able to thank some
people who are in this room without whom
I simply would not be in front of you
today both professor Ron Smith and Laura
Bono the Center for Earth Observation
took on this Egyptology and
archaeological studies student when she
probably didn't have the strongest
physics background 15 years ago and I
will remain forever grateful for their
kindness and patience as I learned how
to do remote sensing and as I tell my
students today if an Egyptologist can
learn how to do this you can too I also
want to thank even though he's not in
the room professor William Kelly Simpson
who was a residential fellow of Timothy
Dwight college I work for him
all my years here and his kindness and
generosity and support have really
allowed me to pursue my career so it
just want to acknowledge his his support
before I get going so it's been an
interesting week for me I promise you
that when I took on when when I was back
and forth in with with Mary and stuff
one about coming here I had no idea the
Vikings news was going to break this
week so I've changed up my presentation
a little bit on the last 15 to 20
minutes
I want to give you a little bit of a
sneak peek behind the scenes and things
that you're not going to see in the PBS
Nova program tonight which is airing at
nine it's streamable online kiss you in
case you don't don't have a television
so before I really get going
I want to talk to you about my title the
future of archaeology question mark you
know any time there's a new technology
there's a big question about well is
that some new silver bullet solution how
can we really be critical about the
technology and what I want to show you
today is that wall satellite remote
sensing is an amazing tool it's it's the
starting point it allows us to focus our
efforts on the ground to be much more
targeted where we dig where we survey
and also I think this is its real
strength to allow us to think in a much
bigger way and ask far broader questions
then we were able are ever able to ask
before so we can really do some some new
and innovative
anthropologically driven research and
ask bigger and better questions so what
is space archaeology I know there's
probably been a little bit of eye
rolling from some of my colleagues for
the use of that term now we all wear
different hats today I'm an
archaeologist I'm an Egyptologist
I'm a remote sensing specialist I'm a
mom and on and on and on we we all have
these different different titles and you
know within archaeology there are
different specializations or people who
specialize in human remains but people
who specialize in geo archaeology there
are people who specialize in aerial
archaeology so the reason that I call
myself a space archaeologist is because
of NASA NASA actually has a space
archaeology program to fund researchers
to do what I do so I figure if NASA can
call what I do space archaeology I must
be a space archaeologist and it's
certainly a great way to get kids
excited about what I do so just a little
little note about that so what do we do
well the field of remote sensing and
archaeology is incredibly broad of
course there are so many different
satellite and
plane based datasets that we use to find
new sites to find environmental features
that may indicate where ancient sites
might be to do to do modeling to do
predictive modeling this is just one 3d
model we did using lidar data which was
collected of the Turkana basin in Kenya
this is a collaborative project my team
and I did with the Leakey's last year
there are all these different kinds of
things you can do with the data and it
ultimately depends on what your
questions are I want to talk to you
first about how the resolution has
improved over the last 30 or so years so
this is a Landsat satellite image of the
Giza Plateau from the early 1980s and as
you can see well you really can't but
this is from a worldview 3 satellite
image so this has a resolution of 30
meters this has a resolution of 30
centimeters 10 inches the resolution of
the imagery has improved significantly
I think you can see anyone there but you
can actually now see people from space
mainly their shadows but as the
resolution improves and improves we're
just going to be able to see so much
more and not so much more so how does
this work I want to quickly walk you
through a case study this is a
publication that is coming out next
month it's already paired online and The
Bulletin of the American schools of
Oriental research with my collaborator
dr. Chris Tuttle and we had decided that
it would be really interesting to apply
high resolution satellite imagery to the
site of Petra just because obviously
it's a large site and when everyone
thinks that Petra you think of the this
is a landscape by the way large rocky
hilly mountainous covers a vast
landscape and everyone knows Petra
because of the famous treasuring or
so-called treasury so the question was
to what extent can we look at this
landscape where people have been
intensely surveying for over a hundred
years to see if we could find anything
potentially new and we thought well
maybe we're going to find some
some potential Cairns some small
structures but when we did the initial
pass-through just looking we first start
off by looking at visual imagery to get
a lay of the land this interesting
features showed up and in processing the
imager said this is a world view to
satellite image you can see this
interesting rectilinear form that has
shown up here and if you look off to the
left you can see kind of some some
blinds running down the cliff I was a
bit skeptical when I first saw this I
thought well like the lines look
straight they look anthropomorphic in
nature but not really sure but certainly
worth checking out on the ground so
crest took his drone team out you can
see this interesting rectilinear feature
so it's definitely definitely man-made
and this is the picture that he took
let's zoom in a little bit what you're
looking at is a massive monumental
platform 180 metres long and 60 metres
wide this is an absolutely massive
structure it's a really interesting a
really interesting vantage point you can
go from there and look in the central
city I'm you can see interior structures
you can see very clear delineation of
different levels of building it needs to
be excavated and it's interesting
because this is only a kilometer south
of the main city it's one of the largest
monumental platforms that's ever been
found at Petra it dates from the
Nabataean to Roman periods Chris took a
team out and did extensive survey they
found a couple hundred years of ceramic
evidence so it was clearly a very
important structure that was in long use
and you can actually see it from you can
when you stand on top of it you can see
the main city but when you sand in the
main city you can't see the structure so
we decided to call our article hiding in
plain sight because that's what it is
now if someone were walking over this
would they have seen it maybe I mean
it's pretty obvious when you're walking
on the ground you can see column basis
and certainly these structures are quite
apparent but no one thought to look so
this is really the power of the imagery
it shifts your perspective just that
little bit and allows you to overturn
long-held assumptions about very Noam
Lansky
so just from this study we've done at
petrol and in other parts of the world I
think we need to begin reassessing most
of the world's well-known sites because
again and again when my colleagues look
at satellite data for these really
well-known sites like angkor wat and
Caracol and elsewhere they find the
sites were significantly larger and
there are other sites nearby related to
them so of course and relating to the
the incredible week you have coming up
next week we've all seen terrible
destruction that's gone on in the last
few years from ISIL and elsewhere and
there's a big question about what can we
do to stop it how do we know where it's
happening and how it's happening now of
course we see images like this because
we see them from space we see the before
and the after of this temple at hemara
but of course it's way too dangerous to
look on the ground and I got involved
with this work starting in January of
2011 when the Arab Spring started I'll
never forget on top we're square you see
the pink building in the background
that's the Cairo Museum this is
basically the backyard of most
Egyptologists when they go to Egypt we
hang out there we go to our NGO before
we start our seasons and when we saw the
tens of thousands of protesters we
couldn't believe it
two days later we woke up I'll let me
forget that Saturday morning and we
heard that the Cairo Museum had been
looted and it felt to us like someone
had died we didn't know the extent of
the destruction we thought oh my gosh
it's like the museum and Baghdad what
what has been taken we also started
hearing rumors of looting at sites south
of Cairo
but then images like this started
circulating of course the people have
Carlos stood up he said not this is not
the Baghdad Museum we're willing to
protect this site but this big question
how much looting had gone on in Egypt
how could we begin to map it so I was
approached by National Geographic to
examine some of the sites south of Cairo
to get some initial satellite imagery
now this is a site of Abu Cyr the site
of Jesus to the north the site of scars
to the south you
see pits on the ground but you really
can't see how big they are you really
can't see what may have been taken and
this is the power of the imagery so I
fortunately had just been in Egypt at
the end of 2010 I had imagery from many
many sites so this is the before image
and this is the after now this is basic
visual interpretation clearly you can
see about 200 looting pits you see the
darker area with the oval around it
evidence of bulldozing so clearly
looting had happened but what was
interesting is that in looking at other
data looting hadn't happened in other
places where people said it had so we're
able to use scientific data to dispel
rumors and show the world exactly what
was going on and this is in 2013 the
images a little dark but you can see the
area's been bulldozed and actually
they're preparing to build an illegal
cemetery so when people think of looting
incite destruction on they often mess
modern encroachment and modern building
which can actually be a far greater can
cause far greater damage to sites than
simple simple looting so that's
something else we have to think about as
part of a delegation out of the George
Washington University we went to meet
with the Ministry of Antiquities Foreign
Minister and a number of other Egyptian
officials at the Parliament building to
share our data and discuss future
solutions together I can see us standing
in front of one of these looting pits
what what I learned is that the looters
know exactly where to target they don't
have to dig around before they find a
looting bit if I'm the looting pet and
down they go fortunately the Egyptian
government intervened there started to
be some infilling but at these sites the
question is what was taken but many of
them unfortunately we found human bone
we found bits of coffin bits of mummy
clearly the tombs that at least been
partly intact before the looters got to
them so then there was the question of
at what scale is this looting going on
so we expanded our search to the south
we looked at the entirety of the pyramid
fields we looked at the site list which
we'll talk about in a few minutes and
elsewhere started doing the math
crunching the numbers figuring out the
size and the area and the extent because
what you're able to do on the satellite
imagery is drop polygons around each
looting pit
to detect its exact area and exact size
we weren't just getting a looting pit
counting number but a size count because
it's one thing to scramble around a
little bit and maybe dig some small
holes in the ground it's something else
entirely to dig a three meter by three
meter square where you've encountered a
large tomb and you've gone down to Luton
so this helped us to get our heads
around some of the math but then we
decided to expand things even further so
the issue with doing large scale remote
sensing across an entire country is the
cost of the imagery and most countries
around the world simply can't afford
countrywide satellite remote sensing
data it would cost tens of millions of
dollars so my team and I decided to
develop a methodology using Google Earth
open-source satellite imagery and GIS
techniques that could be replicated in
GIS free where GIS stands for geographic
information systems it's a map storage
and aggregation tool you can do
statistical analyses in it and we wanted
to create a methodology that could be
replicated by anyone anywhere this is a
study that came out in the archeology
journal antiquity just a few months ago
and what we did is we analyzed Google
Earth imagery from 2002 to 2013 at every
single Egyptian archaeological site over
a 12-year period and you can see here we
created a countrywide as far as we know
this is the first countrywide looting
density map that's ever been done
we found looting at 267 sites and mapped
over 200,000 looting pits that was not a
fun couple of months and I think we can
do better with with automation and
computer learning but it just goes to
show you the importance of large-scale
analysis some really big data to
understand the subtleties of what's
going on so this is what we did so you
can see the looting pets in the upper
left hand image we drew little polygons
around them so this is one side in the
Egyptian Delta you can see that more
than half the site has been looted we
mapped the amount of looting that
happened at the site and at some sites
what you can see progressions so from
2009 to 2013 this is a site just north
of the Pyramid of M&M hat the third at -
sure
you can see major amounts of looting and
there's an illegal extension of the
cemetery that also takes out part of the
site so here's what we found
what we found did nothing less than
overturn the commonly held assumption
that looting got significantly worse in
Egypt after the start of the Arab Spring
it did and yet it didn't
looting started to get bad in Egypt in
2009 after the recession it's pretty
steady up and down a little bit and then
we see this massive spike in 2009 and we
cross-reference this with with inflation
data with GDP tourism numbers and all
the economic numbers that would cause
the bottom to fall out of the Egyptian
economy so the reason it got bad in 2011
after the Arab Spring is because it was
already bad it was already that
trendline was already tipping up and the
Arab Spring made it go faster and I
think and this is what my colleagues who
work in sneer in Iraq and elsewhere have
said I think the story is the same there
so whatever you've heard in the news big
data has shown that it's actually not
quite the case but this shows the
importance of really think thinking
deeply and asking big questions about
why things are happening and can we even
begin to use this to predict when
looting might happen it might get worse
in other parts of the world so then we
of course projected the amount of
looting in site damage at all the sites
over time because our question was when
will all the sites in Egypt be affected
by looting assuming a standard
progression and the answer is 2040 2039
2040 depending on which of our models
you use pretty close and that's very
interesting because this is a completely
coincidental
it matches the so-called tipping point
for when you're gonna see major
environmental changes and I think
potentially they're connected so there's
the work from space but then there's the
important work on the ground so mapping
looting is only the beginning you've got
to go in on the ground you've got to
have what's called community archaeology
you have to figure out why these
problems are happening engage with
communities to create ultimately
new economic opportunities because
that's really the only way that we're
going to be able to stop polluting or at
least one of the ways we're gonna be
able to stop it so this site now which
is called blushed is an incredibly
important site it was the Royal burial
site for Egypt's Kings in the Middle
Kingdom that the great Renaissance
period a time of great resurgence in art
and architecture and literature and if
you have taken introductory hieroglyphs
here at Yale that's your learning middle
Egyptian you're learning the language
from that time period I absolutely love
this particular period it's it's really
an amazing one and I've been very
fortunate I have a brand-new project in
collaboration with Egypt's Ministry of
Antiquities and we went to lashed to
start excavation work this past December
so this is an image showing the amount
of looting that's happened just in North
lished I'm since before and after and
you can see there are hundreds of pits
there almost a thousand tombs looted at
leashed we first went to do a ground
truthing trip about a year ago and we
could see that many of the tombs were
probably intact how do we know this
typically tombs in Egypt are called
mastaba tombs that's Arabic for bench
and you can see there's a mud brick
that's covering the shaft Jim looters
broke through the mud brick you could
see the area littered with my brick and
went down now was it looted in antiquity
maybe I can't tell you that what I can
tell you is at least the top of the
mastaba was intact and we've seen a
pretty significant spike in the number
of Middle Kingdom antiquities that the
Egyptian government has recovered from
illegal sales overseas so clearly a lot
of these tombs are intact so we decided
to work in an area in South flesh now
initially I had applied for permission
from the ministry to do survey work so
my team and I were on the ground mapping
these looted pits and we thought we
would potentially see what we could do
to conserve any one of them or at least
begin to protect them but my Egyptian
co-director Mohammed Yosef was very good
friend said look there's this amazing
tomb we think it's been totally looted
but given what we've just found these
gorgeous inscribed blocks we think the
looters are going to come back
you know what kind of emergency
conservation or excavation can we do to
protect this really important and we
don't know who who it is we don't know
who the owner is but what can we do so
you can see a pretty standard
upper-class Egyptian tomb you've got
three niches it would have originally
been a rock-cut tomb this would have
been the roof it's collapsed in
antiquity and I thought well you know
it's our first season of course we want
to make sure we develop this as a
long-term collaboration we employed many
local people when we started to clear
the tomb and clean it and I thought the
looters had gotten most things but we
started to find amazing inscribed pieces
this is a absolutely gorgeous gorgeous
piece color is very well preserved we
found many many fragments like this one
and then much to my surprise part way
through the season we uncovered the name
of the tomb owner on Taff we discovered
many of his titles he was overseer of
the army he was overseer of the Treasury
he was a sole companion of the king in
other words a pretty important guy and
not surprising that he would have this
very nice trim so he was the general and
the time of some wall strip the first
son of Amon and had the first hoods
demas and wall strat the first M&M that
the first had that both had their tombs
at leashed with thousands and thousands
of tombs there you see that the Middle
Kingdom capital of itched Howey
which is from about 3800 years ago was
located just to the east of the real
pyramid field and so you have to think
of course the courtiers and the artisans
and the princes and princesses and all
the people in the courts of the Kings
would have been buried at leashed which
is why the tombs are so rich much to our
surprise as we started excavating the
niche we found this stunning intact fall
sort was originally down we've we put it
up we're able to read most of what's
there
learn a lot about on teff and that you
can actually even though it's partly cut
out see him seated here what's
interesting about this tomb it's been
looted multiple times so these tombs
which looters come in now and loot
probably have long and rich histories
that need to be untangled so we can
better understand
and why they look the way they do we
really don't have any sense of this with
regards to looted loot it site so I'm
there I'm talking to my Egyptian
co-director Mohammed Yosef we have a
wonderful crew of goof teas these
amazing Egyptian diggers from from Upper
Egypt just digging a site it's not even
close to enough so in because this was
such a rich site what we decided to do
is we built a guardhouse we install the
lighting system we bricked up the niches
of the tomb so the looters couldn't get
in anymore and we're paying for guards
year-round to help protect us now this
is just one tomb at one site but it's
the beginning hopefully of a very
long-term and rich working relationship
we employed a lot of local people paid
them very well I mean the idea is what
can we do at the site to engage local
people and what we heard this amazing
story at the end of our season a couple
of the our local workers came up to us
and they said look don't don't be angry
with us we took part in the looting at
the site the looters are desperate these
men have nothing they'd have to feed
their families and frankly we'd you know
a lot of us would loot if we had to if
we were that desperate I don't blame
them and they said you know we had no
idea this stuff was important to anyone
we never learned in school most of them
can't read and write by the way so you
know but now we know it's important you
know you've paid us well we're very
proud we feel like it's our heritage so
by making local people a part of your
projects by treating them with respect
by engaging them by finding out what
they want to get from the site I think
there's real hope for many of these
threatened sites around the world so
we're gonna use this site as like a
laboratory to test what works what
doesn't work some things may work some
things may not you know I would love to
for example build a playground and a
picnic area at the site so that kids and
families feel welcome because a lot of
people feel like they don't own it and
it's they're not a part of it so I want
to take a couple minutes and talk about
my my TED Prize wish certainly an
incredible honor
and you know an idea that I've been
kicking around with my colleagues for a
while is you know how do we begin to
solve this huge global problem of luden
what's going on not just in Egypt in the
Middle East but just everywhere in the
US Central America Europe China you name
it it's going on so there are so many
different solutions there's not a
one-size-fits-all and my idea is to
create something not to fix looting next
year in five years because that's not
going to happen we need to start
planning long term and getting people
invested so that in 20 years there's no
more looting there's going to be a long
slow process and I believe that by
getting people invested and making them
part of discovery we just might have a
chance so the idea is using the Ted
prize money to build an online citizen
science crowdsource platform and what
you'll be able to do is log on and this
is not the actual platform this is just
a kind of a teaser but you'll be able to
engage with a satellite imagery and
we'll be pre-processing it this is in
close collaboration with National
Geographic and a company called digital
globe which is the largest provider of
high-resolution satellite imagery in the
world
they're very kindly providing the
imagery we're partnering together with
Ted to build this platform and the idea
is you know as you engage with it you'll
course learn what satellite imagery is
how to use it what different parts of
the light spectrum are and you'll get to
mark where there might be looting pits
or where there might be sites they'll be
rich examples off to the side of you can
see here what what you're seeing you
seem looting pits you're seeing
encroachment are you seeing different
kinds of sites and as you find things
you'll get to engage with very rich
content and learn more about the culture
of that you're dealing with and I don't
know yet where we're going to start
we're still working on that developing
senemo used with countries but certainly
if we work somewhere that does not have
English as a primary language we're
going to have make sure the platform is
in the language of that country so the
kids that
country can engage her that that's
crucial there's a thing I want to make
clear is there's no GPS or mapping
information that's going to be a part of
the site so you'll know you're in
southern Mexico or northern England but
there will never be any indicators that
show you exactly where you are because
at the end of the day we have to protect
the sites we have to protect this data
all the data we gather from it is going
to be shared with authorities so
officials from that country professional
archaeologists and then we're going to
provide grants for team for teams to go
out and explore what the crowd finds and
then the crowd will get to further
participate by seeing how those sites
are excavated so with social media with
periscope with with Google+ they'll get
to be taken on these adventures and
participate in the sites they've helped
to discover so it's kind of a complete
process and I know crowdsourcing mores
worked very well in other parts of the
world this is their much bigger scale so
we'll be learning as we go so I'd like
to end my talk Alaskan to 15 or 20
minutes by talking about something that
I promise you
egyptologists generally don't talk about
which is the Vikings I am probably a lot
more surprised than all of you to be
talking about this at Yale where with
all due respect to the North specialists
in the audience I for me when I was an
undergraduate
the Romans felt a little too early for
me but this is how life goes kind of how
I got involved this is about two years
ago after I'd done a program with the
BBC and discovered science on the Roman
world and I did half my PhD on the late
Roman Empire in in Egypt so it wasn't
really a big step for me and that's
really the work you saw with at Petra
that's where that's one of the projects
we did so in the Rome program I'd
collaborated with my team with the vers
specialists and we now have got a number
of peer-reviewed publications so it
worked out really nicely and the BBC had
said well why don't you Vikings next and
I said why don't you find a specialist
because I don't know anything about the
Vikings aside from though one day I
teach in my introductory archaeology
class you know I know it's
in diverse field I know enough to know
that there's no way I could possibly
learn enough to do a project like this
Vikings and I kept pushing back and they
kept pushing so eventually they provided
some seed money where we did some
initial work and my hypothesis was at
the time that we wouldn't find anything
I will go to that in a second so let me
talk to you about the search for North
America so start with with what what do
the saiga say the sagas were written in
the 13th century AD and we need to learn
about Finland and the Viking voyage to
North America through the saga of Erik
the Red Messiah of the Greenlanders and
we know that the Vikings went from of
course from Scotland to the Faroe
Islands to Iceland and then on to
Greenland in 7sr 1890 to 680 we know
that Leif went to Finland this mythical
area potentially with grapes potentially
not that's the whole area of debate
around a thousand AD and we know as well
there seemed to be if you believe the
sigh goes multiple trips so we know the
last survivors in Greenland
we're on 450 80s so the only site and
this is the site in in Greenland you can
see the map how the Norse expanded and
moved to to the new world we also know
there have been a lot of hoaxes I teach
a course called archaeological hoaxes
scans and documentary disasters it's one
of my favorite courses to teach and I
spend about a week talking about all
these crazy hoaxes that have happened
you know supposed biking rune stones
that are bogus all these searches for
another Norse site in North America of
course you part of the Minnesota Vikings
they didn't reach Minnesota I'm hope no
one here is from Minnesota all due
respect you have a great state it's
beautiful but no Vikings so so you know
when I start when I took on this project
I thought I don't want to be one of
these crazy people just just I I was
very very cautious and I'm pretty a
pretty skeptical person regardless
but you know the question is were there
other sites so we know of course you
have the connection to the Vinland map I
won't dwell on it too long I know it's a
sore spot for some folks here anyway
today there's only been one confirmed
North site in North America the side of
lawn so a meadow if any of you I don't
know if any of you have ever been its
Newfoundland is a fabulous province it's
stunningly beautiful the people they're
wonderful so this is a site that was
found in the 1960s by being studs and
what they did is the use of sagas and
they looked at the places that were
mentioned and the geographical
descriptions in them and they followed
what was described
hello land and and and Leafs booty air
so these these lands that were described
in the sagas as being treated have lots
of trees have wide beaches and they use
that to help them find Lonzo meadow and
was huge find you know very sensational
in the 1960s we know now for sure it's a
North site they've had 150 radiocarbon
dates you see these halls probably about
60 to 100 people didn't last very long
and only one object so the question is
could there be another site or other
sites and my hypothesis was according to
Brigida Wallace that one of the original
excavators of Lonzo meadow one of her
theories is that there were never any
other sites wants a meadow was that I
said okay if she's the expert let's
assume that there are no other sites in
Newfoundland or elsewhere you know but
let's look so of course my team and I
examined many North sites how do they
express themselves in different kinds of
satellite imagery what about indigenous
sites we looked at many sites from the
Inuit from the little messages people
from the Dorset the Paleo Eskimo how do
what a different structures look like
from different periods of time and
different peoples who lived in eastern
Canada for the last 2,000 years we
started by looking at open source
satellite imagery if we'd gotten
high-resolution satellite imagery for
this whole area it would have cost many
many millions of dollars so we just
started looking and this took my team my
team and I quite some time
and we narrowed it down to a few
hotspots about 50 or so we then got
high-resolution aerial photography
because again getting satellite imagery
for 50 sites is a lot of money we then
narrowed it down to six hotspots
that's about reasonable so we got
high-resolution multispectral satellite
imagery we can process it and see
different different parts of the light
spectrum so this is what showed up
initially you can see on Google Earth
there's a kind of some dark staining on
this point so we're in southwestern
Newfoundland
I thought well that's interesting so we
got satellite imagery and we processed
it this is what's called an NDVI which
stands for a normalized difference
vegetation index and you can't see
vegetation health differences generally
with the visible eye because chlorophyll
which which vegetation contains reflects
much more strongly in the near-infrared
part of a light spectrum but the nice
thing about the satellite of a drink is
it can see what the human eye can't so
what you're seeing all these dark stains
you can see this long line here you can
see this rectilinear form here there's
another one here there's a really
interesting ovoid structure in that part
of the image which you can see a bit
better here what you're seeing our
vegetation health signature differences
because of what's buried beneath the
ground now when we saw this it's working
with my my remote sensing team lead
chase child's we thought well that looks
a lot like something anthropomorphic
versus something geological not sure
what it is we made no assumptions
whatsoever about the particular period
of time that this came from so because
this project was being done by the book
we applied for permission from the
public archeology offices of
Newfoundland Labrador this wonderful
woman named dr. Martha Drake and
explained the project to her and said
please don't think we're completely
crazy and she said no no actually this
was really interesting because no one
has used satellite imagery before to
look for new sites in Newfoundland or
anywhere in eastern Canada like this so
worst case scenario you're developing a
new methodology to look for sites and
because you're not assuming what this
site might be it could be historic it
could be indigenous
Jezza but being nor sir teeny-tiny
but test it out on the ground and we've
got a vast area to cover so you know
this new methodologies are very
interesting so we went out my team went
out in the fall of 2014 this is a point
rosey it's strikingly beautiful you
can't see anything on the ground by the
way those are those are four by four
tracks but very flat covered in grass
gorgeous vantage point it's interesting
about point Rosie is it has rocky
beaches to the north and south less than
a kilometer away it has perfect beaches
and a gorgeous Inlet full of fish there
would have been abundant natural
resources there trees but it's got iron
bog iron from a bog so people could make
iron it has deer lots of Wildlife and
what's really interesting about what
this particular part of Newfoundland the
cod roe Valley it's the only part of the
Newfoundland even today where there's
agriculture and that's definitely
mentioned in the Saiga
so just landscape wise it's ideal but
again we're not making any assumptions
about the period of the site at this
time so we started off by doing magnet
amador can adapt aside there are a lot
of images I wish I could show you but
the the we're still getting our post
excavation results back we're currently
working on a publication for peer review
which will be submitting pretty soon so
there's a lot I can't quite show you yet
and it's there's a lot that's not
featured in the program but when Dave
gatherings are our mag expert surveyed
in the field we found my net ometer
signatures matched the saddle head
imagery really well which showed that
what was there was anthropomorphic
versus natural so thanks to National
Geographic BBC and PBS Nova we got
generous funding to go back last summer
to do test excavations we worked
together with dr. Frederic Schwartz
who's the official permit holder and he
is an expert in historic archaeology and
indigenous archaeology so the public
archaeology office said look seaming wet
your font get a find is not Norse at
least you'll know right away if it's
historic or indigenous dr. dr. Schwartz
has over 30 years of experience for us
we had many specialists who were
consultants getting out to the site was
interesting it's located on a point in
the absolute middle of nowhere you can
see the Tucker Moore you can see just
really
tough conditions and you had to be
really careful because if you didn't
watch where you're going you could fall
50 feet and that would be that there
were bears we didn't see anything
goodness but I've never had to carry
bear spray before it's a new world for
me but yeah I mean it is it is just
absolutely beautiful part of the world
you can see the view here really really
really stunning part of the universe and
when we excavate it we had the woods we
had the ocean we had the mountains in
the background really really a pleasant
place to work although cold I have
invested in a lot of icebreaker gear the
first time in my life so we established
a psyche read you know good archeology
is good archeology it doesn't matter
where in the world you're working
there's been a lot of the expert advice
from our North specialist colleagues we
set up a grid for excavation we chose
very carefully shows some distinct units
because of the results from the
magnetometer and the satellite remote
sensing to target some very specific
areas so this area to the north we tried
to see if we could find some subsurface
architecture to map the satellite
imagery on what we found even though
it's really mucky you can see some lines
running through this and what you're
looking at is possible turf walls we've
shown this to North specialists and
they're like we thought we were
skeptical but it actually does look a
lot like a turf wall so it matches at
least the very least we're able to say
additionally okay what we're seeing
under the ground matches the satellite
imagery no indigenous cultures used turf
just kind of rough turf but not
organized turf like this it's certainly
historic peoples would have would have
built things out of wood so we started
excavating and eventually we hit what
we're calling a hearth you see that
large fire cracked stone you can see
basically digging in a bog conditions
are very different today it's much
wetter we think of the site then it
would have been a long time ago so the
site filled up with water pretty quickly
you can see what appears to be turf
walls or dirt we're calling it a turf
light feature we're being very very
careful but what's interesting about
fire crack rock is there's a bowl that's
lined with stones and we found
20 pounds of bog iron roasted bog iron
by the way just within that scoop so
some experts have come out in the press
of course this is very controversial and
said it's accidental accidental burning
of bog iron we see the seller I'm like
okay I'm willing to take like you know a
couple handfuls of bog iron that's in a
bog and you make a fire and some of it
gets burned but 20 pounds of bog iron
that's directly in the bowl of a fire
with a conch almost like a concreted
carbonized stone that's not coincidence
and by the way this hearth looks a lot
like a lot of other hearts that my North
specialist colleagues have seen in other
parts of the world so anyway you can see
a better shot of it here you can just
see the bowl right here what's
interesting you can't really see it very
well in this picture but it's there's a
stone lined feature running off to the
north and our question is if you're
going to heat something there's probably
going to be some kind of a chimney could
it be that could it could this begin and
what's interesting is the wind would
pick up and it would be the strongest at
that part of the site so the Norse knew
what they were doing when they were
constructing these cars and you had to
get very high temperatures so of course
they're gonna put their fires in the
part of the site or the wind is
strongest so here's some of the bog iron
from roasting different sizes a lot of
big pieces a lot of small pieces there's
some other close close-up shots of the
turf you can see it interestingly
aligned we didn't hit the corner like I
said we only had a short amount of time
there but you can see it stops if this
were natural it would keep going and it
stops directly on the dense clay like
feature or surface natural surface into
which the actual hearth was dug so it
was put there intentionally by who good
question you can see the strips right
there pretty pretty clear so post
excavation of course we've analyzed the
bog iron carefully and what we did and I
can't show the image but you'll see it
tonight our colleague dr. Tom Burch who
is a Norse mythology specialist
cut open several pieces of bong iron and
looked at an under scanning electron
microscope because my initial thought
when I and you'll hear me say this in
the program tonight was it slag slag
looks very bubbly and if you look at
some of these pitched pieces they look
very bubbly it looks like slag it's got
a have to it but when he looked at it
order the scanning electron microscope
and even he was fooled by the way when
the Norse mythology specialist tells you
it slag you go okay but you don't tell
me I'm not the expert but when he cut it
in half what he found is it's roasted so
what the Norse would do is they collect
bog iron which is very crumbly and easy
to break apart this stuff isn't easy to
break apart at all and they put it into
a hearth and rather than put it in a
furnace at a very high degree where it
would have exploded because of its it's
so damp that would have gently dried it
out and roasted it to get off some of
the impurities which is why we saw the
bubbling and under the scanning electron
microscope what dr. Burton is colleagues
saw was iron ore with at eighty-five to
ninety percent concentration so whoever
I'm being careful whoever roasted this
knew what they were doing it's the first
days in iron production so we've had a
number of radiocarbon dates taken of us
that we've had thirteen and by the way
Lanza meadow has had over 150 give us
some time we'll build up to that there's
really poor organic preservation on site
you'll see kind of a Down moment in the
documentary we the only two bits of
organic or decent organic remains we had
on the site where for berries but
they're from a much higher contact stand
they're much later but that's okay
you'll want to get a full date range of
sites what's interesting is that piece
of wood was found on top of the turf
structor flake structure in the north it
dates to the 1600s the first occupation
in this part of Newfoundland wasn't
until the mid to late 1700s so our first
date for the site predates anyone on the
site and that is about 30 centimetres
above our first occupation layer what's
really interesting
is the date that we have from the
carbonized material on the bog iron
which is that that is not in the program
I never mind don't shoot the messenger
we have another date of about it's 806
from the bog iron itself obviously we
need to go back we need to do a lot more
dating but the date ranges from a good
context on site to dates
obviously two dates doth not a site make
it's the beginning but they're from good
contacts are from the 9th to 13th
centuries ad that is suggestive and also
this cap is very suggestive because if
we have a date of 1650 for 30
centimeters above are our first bits of
turf wall obviously that came far later
so we have a lot of work left to do on
site you know we're still we're
collecting all of our post excavation
reports this summer we're going to be
going back to point Rosie I'm so just
kind of sum is it isn't it ok we we've
got definitive bog iron roasting so no
matter what without even giving an
attribute of a specific culture we have
the second pre-columbian iron processing
site in North America I feel very
comfortable saying that I think the
evidence is very clear our North
specialist colleagues at least most of
them feel very comfortable saying that
we have no indigenous remains whatsoever
you typically find a lot of flint on
sites nothing no indigenous groups
smelted iron we have no historic remains
on site nothing ceramic and you find
tons and tons of ceramics and iron and
what's interesting too is historic
peoples would have brought their iron
with them so they certainly did not
there's no evidence according to
historians of any historic groups or
European and French smelting we don't we
thought we might have some clenched
bolts or rivets or nails but it's just
the way the bog iron from well I guess
they look like it we're hoping going
back this summer to to do more than that
by the way the Dorset Inuit used
meteoric iron
now they do work with iron but but not
not in this way so this summer we'll be
going back with a full team of
specialists we we have what could
potentially be additional features on
site that are related to the processing
of bog iron certainly going to be
looking into some of the buildings you
know there could be some domestic
contacts will be doing detailed surveys
so we're very very early days I'm still
bewildered by this whole thing but I
think I hope you've been able to see how
cautious I've been I'm not calling this
a North settlement so regardless of what
you've read in the press I'm not calling
it that I'm saying it's suggestive it's
exciting it's the first site in 50 years
that could potentially be a Norse site
if it is to call it a settlement that's
that is the next word in archaeology it
is at best a small farm
could it be bigger yes we have but we
have years and years of work to do at
Lonzo meadow they did three years of
six-month season so that's 18 months of
continuous excavation over three years
before they were comfortable with
calling the site Norse we have done one
two and a half week season please give
us some time obviously you know we've
got to get out here of your reports and
that and the one good thing about having
this news come out is that we have been
contacted by world-class specialists in
Archaea botany and human skeletal
remains and archaea metallurgy and we're
forming a team of outstanding scholars
and scientists to come with us this
summer because we know how much scrutiny
we are now under because of the amount
of attention this is gone and if this is
what it might be the potential is
enormous and we want to do right by the
site and of course connecting back to
the original theme and thinking forward
to next week there's a tremendous
opportunity for tourism western
Newfoundland is incredibly depressed
this could represent an amazing
opportunity for the wonderful people
that helped us to make this season
possible so we're being very careful of
course we're going to involve a lot of
local people a lot of local stakeholder
and the decision-making processes were
working very very closely with the
public archaeology Offices of
Newfoundland and Labrador poor people
they've been inundated with calls too
because we think there's real potential
here so I guess that's really I'm gonna
wrap this up you know you've got
archaeology from space you've got these
big questions that you can help answer
but at the end of the day it's the work
you do on the ground and it's the
relationships you build with local
people that can last a much much longer
time thank you very much for your
attention
nice today but before I pray get to
questions you PBS know but tonight nine
o'clock if you have kids a caveat there
is one there's one section that does
discuss the Viking poop I had nothing to
do with it but for the boys and girls of
a certain age that may prove of great
interest it's very funny so I guess I'll
open it up to any any questions comments
you had mentioned that in looking at the
satellite imagery that you had distilled
it down to sort of six odd spots you
called them are there is there thought
of doing some investigative excavations
that those other sites do or is this one
seem to be the most promising great
question yeah this one seemed to be the
most promising and what we've realized
is that now that we know how sites like
this express themselves both in Google
Earth and the multispectral imagery we
now need to reassess the entirety of the
coastline of Newfoundland because we're
pretty sure that we've missed things you
know if you believe the sagas because
it's how they found the first site there
are probably other sites out there aside
for because you can explain one side
away it's a one-off they came they left
it didn't work if there's two sites from
what I've learned from my norse
colleagues they're going to be more did
they potentially occupy this coastline
as intensively as they occupied other
coastlines obviously they were very
careful of where they pics yeah we did
we have to go back and reanalyze the
imagery but our plan is to do develop
long-term survey strategies in the
region so great question so there is
going to be a National Geographic
magazine article that comes out next
month
it's the June issue but it comes out in
the middle to the end of May and the
cover story is going to be on looting in
Egypt so definitely you don't get
national Geographics but there's a
National Geographic fellow subscribe'
still worthwhile to get the magazine but
it'll be it'll be out in there and
they're definitely gonna be some some
rich
online content connected to it a great
question hi thank you for coming so you
mentioned that like I'm assuming that
there's like millions of photos that you
have to go through at any time and
you're always looking for no sites and
you kind of have to use a sense of
intuition how are you planning to or are
you planning to integrate like you know
AI or neural networks in order to find
more sites so that you don't have to
spend months on months on end looking
for these sites so I've developed one
collaboration with Professor Richard
Granger at Dartmouth University and
we've used AI to automate the process of
looking for looting pits and we've got
about an 85 to 90 percent accuracy the
paper hopefully is at under review right
now it'll be accepted and and we figured
that's about the accuracy of the human
eye I end up throwing out and so does my
team about 1 in 10 looting pits because
or is it a bush is it a shadow we're not
sure so we gear it so that we under
count rather than over count so yeah I
mean we're it's definitely possible to
do machine learning so once we have
started collecting all this data from
the crowdsourcing platform the idea is
to start looking at what patterns people
are picking out you know and is it a
chemical signature or is it a specific
shape obviously different cultures in
the world will express themselves
differently but then doing training and
deep learning to get this process
automated so it's so what we can do is
batch feed satellite imagery into into
the computer I'd get it to spend on all
the hot spots and then get the crowd to
confirm those rather than the other area
but I get this is what a lot of us doing
this remote sensing work are thinking
about
thank you the technology of space
technologies the single technology or a
bunch of technologies and then the
looting in Egypt is it national or
international and are you following the
news about the kV 62 what do you think
excuse me
one of those questions is more loaded
than the other two so M yeah the looting
in Egypt so first question I use
off-the-shelf remote sensing software to
do what I do so they're different a
couple of different packages or das
imagine your map or env to do the remote
sensing work those are standard used by
biologists by meteorologists by
scientists all over the world i I can't
code but I work with students were much
smarter than I am that can so certainly
you're always you know they're
developing little add-ons to to the
programs and you know the looting in
Egypt you know why is it happening is
that that people are coming in from
other parts of the world and saying I'd
like Middle Kingdom statue
I would like mummy from the Ptolemaic
period you know is they're kind of
concierge service looting like there is
in the art world where it suggested that
very wealthy people are behind a lot of
the art thefts I think there is I think
that is going on but the problem is the
the laws or lacks the you know
import-export rules and regulations are
often in big us and also if you look at
people like ice Homeland Security you
know they're doing it the best job they
can but they're only a handful of people
that are working for them they they
can't stand the tide as fast as they'd
like with regards to the other news
which one of my colleagues termed no 40
ting I did not come up with that I think
the child that so how do I say this
okay we with this Norse discuss
potential nurse discovery right we've
been very very careful we started off
with a hypothesis that there was nothing
came up with something very suggestive
and I think my colleagues were much more
excited about
then I am and then I'm not a specialist
I understand it's important but it's not
what I do so we will continue to be
skeptical and when we'll continue to use
good science and until we know beyond a
shadow of a doubt it's Norse I will not
call it a definitive nor sight I think
that's the safe route what Nick Reeves
has done with with this possible to miss
he's come out and said it's definitely
Nefertiti there's definitely something
there and when my colleagues say there's
definitely something there it's
problematic because it could be a full
range of possibilities the rock in the
Valley of the Kings is very porous
they're often voids and you have to be
really really careful when you're doing
GPR work you have to understand the
local geology in a way that allows you
to account for the full range of
possibilities so let's just say there
were a void or or a room let's not call
it Nefertiti let's call it a chamber I
think we need to be really careful and
really skeptical right these very
sensational claims can overtake the news
something I've certainly learned in the
last week with what's happened with this
discovery I'm actually very cautious you
know I think I think all of us wish Nick
Reeves the best I think a lot of us are
waiting and seeing but I think we just
have to be really careful do you very
very careful because I think I think
that the story isn't that there's the
tomb of Nefertiti I think the story is
that we can use these amazing new
innovative technologies to find entirely
new tombs period I think that's the cool
story but what do I know when you're
looking at a hot spot would it be
beneficial to bring drones with more
sensitive cameras that can see in a
broader range of spectra so that you can
then look at your site from different
eyes that's a great question and yet we
agree a hundred percent what we're
hoping to do this summer is bring drones
out and there's a wonderful program in
the iPhone just FLIR which allows you to
look in thermal
so you can attach that to a drone and
actually see you know is it showing up
differently in the infrared but longer
term we're definitely planning on going
back with drones getting getting a light
our flight flown you need to do this to
get point cloud data to be able to see
under the trees where we think there
potentially might be other features it's
very expensive
drones are cheaper but yeah definitely
at getting a hyperspectral camera
attached to it that's some of the work
it didn't talk about today but that we
did in this collaborative project with
up with the Leakey's at Lake Turkana and
instead of looking at eight or nine
bands in the light spectrum you're able
to look at over 200 I agree completely I
think I think the ship side is going to
show up in a much higher resolution and
in we're going to be able to pick out
the discrete parts of the light spectrum
instead of these broader ranges that you
have in satellite bands so for sure
that's that's part of our long-term
research thank you
just to clarify when you sent a sediment
sample for a radiocarbon dating it was
the charcoal that was in the or the wood
of the charcoal that was in the iron
right so so we sent different samples so
this was an AMS lab at the University of
Chicago so University of Georgia they
specialized in doing AMS dating so we
sent a sample from a piece of wood this
large root that was found on top of the
site we sent the bog iron itself and
then we sent carbonized material that we
scraped off the surface of this large
rock so those were the three samples
that we sent in but yeah I mean we're
we're working with North specialists to
devise a strategic sampling strategy
because we Eman we meant we didn't get
as many samples as we wanted to with
weather conditions and everything else
but you know this summer we'll be
sampling the turf wall of turf like
structures will be you know will be
hopefully because there could be micro
conditions on site and we'd hope to find
charcoal in that hearth I found
thousands of fragments that were like
this big and you'd pick them up and they
just go because they're so inundated
with water so hopefully we'll find some
some good charcoal samples to did to
date this summer
our last last question can you tell us a
little bit about the project with the
Leakey's what what are you doing there
in Africa sure so um so this is with
with Louis Leakey obviously the family's
been working in that part of the world
for a very long time at our hypothesis
was that or question you know was can
you use hyperspectral cameras and lidar
data to develop predictive models of
where potential fossil find spots might
be so we had a locational data from them
for many sites where they'd found
fossils both hominid and and other other
final final analyses in the end they
said you can we typically find them by
just wandering around because they have
rowed out of the sides of hills and that
takes a long time you know it's not the
conditions aren't great you know can we
focus their search and develop tools to
find hotspots and that's what we were
able to do as part of this study we we
used different parts of the spectrum
from the from the hyperspectral camera
to devise hotspots and zones where they
could then go out and do survey work so
we're working on that publication right
now all right well thank you all very
much really appreciate it
you